let's just throw up your
twitter feed because this is just a
random i mean today's thursday this is a
random thursday for trusted yeah um you
know the tweet opens up with a hand on
the neck and you can see the watch there
and i'll let you read that she tweeted
that yesterday she's a romanian uh porn
actress yeah and then we've got uh you
know tristan here saying this actress is
pretty hot she gets the official
talisman thumbs up hey simps am i doing
it right
sips
[Laughter]
yeah
i figure i figure why not start with
that to sort of set the tone yeah i mean
yeah it's a good one and obviously i
mean if you don't get the joke you know
look at the tweet closer the hand around
her neck that she tweeted and me giving
the official thumbs up
has the exact same diamond rolex watch
so either coincidentally the guy who she
bangs in her spare time because uh you
know has the same watch as me or is
actually me that is the joke everyone
gets it but um yeah it's not that i
you know i don't have any involvement
with the adult entertainment industry i
don't run porn actresses i don't have
any kind of agency like that the thing
is if they if they're hot and they and
they live in romania they're going to
end up on my radar at some point so tv
presenters actresses singers uh a lot of
the romanian porn stars not just her you
know in their spare time they're they
they they hang out with guys too they're
looking for guys to [ __ ] in their spare
time and uh i'm just you know that guy
uh i'm um and and just for the record if
anyone thinks i'm paying the money just
just get that out of your head get that
out of your head right now do people
often challenge you that and say oh you
know he's just paying for them or he's
paying for all those girls
well you know it's it's like this
my you know a friend of ours actually
troy francis said this recently to me he
goes look
all these girls are looking for you know
guys to to [ __ ] in their spare time i'm
six foot four i'm a multi-millionaire
i'm smart i hang out the nice places i
drive the nicest cars i live a lifestyle
that everyone wants to be part of if
they're not [ __ ] me
who are they [ __ ] you know these
little these little geeks on twitter and
these these you know tiny little nerds
would be like oh he's paying them
because they'd have to pay the exact
same girl
this girl in the actual photo she used
to work for me for three years as a
webcam model actually so she's a former
employee of mine and a good friend of
mine who i've known for about five years
uh two years ago she quit webcam
modeling and moved into the porn
industry i wished her luck but you know
she's taking a break from that for the
last seven or eight months she hasn't
shot a boy girl scene i think she was
tweeting about that very recently and
she was in romania she called me asked
what's up and you know we hung out
that's it
you know that you know that my history
with hers is a very long friendship and
if anyone were actually in my face life
or death challenging me as to whether or
not i paid her i could literally just
show him the conversation that i have
with her going back here's oh how's work
how's this
all good when you're next in bucharest
you know
when you say friendship with
women do you like is it the same kind of
friendship that you've got with like
your male friends your brother you know
your cousins the guys that you travel
with or is it a completely different
kind of friendship no zero percent when
i mean friendship
it's like this people always say you
know and i will use a derogatory word to
describe women i do sometimes people
always say i've got my main chick and
i've got my side chick but they don't
really understand what a side chick is a
side chick is just another main chick a
side chick is a fully blown
loving relationship where she's
completely loyal to you should do
anything you say she is your girlfriend
she tells her girlfriends that she has a
boyfriend it's you she doesn't talk to
other men that's what a side chick is
so you have your main chicken you have
your side chicks most people have hoes
and they'll be like oh yeah i've got
side chicks no you don't the kind of
girl who isn't really yours you'll see
once every two or three months if you're
in the same place at the same time and
you're bored you'll go to bed together
that's not your side chick she has
nothing to do with you she's just a hoe
she's like one of those wild pokemon
that you uh encounter sometimes but you
never truly catch
so when i say friend it's a more polite
way of of putting it that way i mean
this girl literally i last saw her over
a year ago and she's been shooting porn
scenes et cetera i don't count her as my
side chick or my main chick or a chick
of mine in any way
so when you say friend it's along the
same sort of context where when you see
two lawyers in court and their opposing
counsel then he'll say my friend sort of
thing you know just i don't i don't have
platonic female friends the closest
thing i have to platonic female friends
that exist the only women i will speak
to and be completely platonic and
friendly with are the girlfriends of my
brother and my cousin and my guys
you